su rigore riesce a raffreddarsi d'estate
porca vacca schifosa gesù come fai
quando hai mal di gola ma vivi da solo
in casa che non c'e la mamma da dove
nascono le pastiglie che comparivano
nella credenza dove cazzo sono tutti
ragazzi e benvenuto che sono video sono
fa vj oggi siamo il nuovo blog su questo
blog i ragazzi volevo fare una cosa che
non ho mai fatto ma che mi chiedete
spesso motivi me lo chiedono che cosa
fate con andata ai raduni tipo made in
internet molti me lo chiedono
io non ho mai fatto un video sufficiente
se non ho mai fatto un video di me che
sono un raduno quindi effettivamente non
sapete che cosa succede quindi ragazzi
in questo video volevo farvi vedere più
o meno com'è andata nell'ultimo raduno
uno a caso insomma alla fine più o meno
è sempre così però per darvi di avere
un'idea succedono queste cose buone vi
dirò allora ragazzi stiamo a bologna
adesso tra poco salire sul palco che
devo cantare ai porti in italia come
tutte
oggi però è venuto qua a bologna una
persona speciale a giudicarmi di questa
grazie a giudicarmi questa per morto
questa persona micio libera per come
canta il mio futuro alla cantante sarà
deciso da fare
la persona in questione grazie rudy che
oggi mi darei un bel sì sei proprio
sicuro che diventino si darà investì
vero fare l'ultima volta che ha detto
sia stato il matrimonio dopodiché sono
no però non si sa mai magari mi stupì io
sono una moglie perfetta rutino
benissimo verde dirà grazie
[Applauso]
qua
[Musica]
mai
mari
[Musica]
marek è un ragazzo che ha mal ingari 130
vaticani alza al cartellone marchi gara
è bellissimo ma anche in gara 3 titolo
di privato telematica
ma che cazzo maghi maghetti maghetto che
dovranno mettersi
greta stravino
[Musica]
la faccia è pronto ma mi ha detto di
scendere per andare a prendere allora
valigia per venire a vedere selena gomez
bayern
[Applauso]
la teneva basilico
[Musica]
dedicato a niger
grazie di tutto e file iso fuori gialli
anche in salerno ci sono premi
[Applauso]
bisogna rubato una ragazza storia
hai un bacino a selena ha ma l'ho
incontrato suo amico sta ragazza ma come
c'è un corso di omino già ma i love e li
lover che non ha accennato dai tg
bene ragazzi più o meno è questo che
succede intorno ad uno e ho cantato
insieme quindi venite raduni che ci
divertiamo e soprattutto c'è un derby
come mi chiedete sicuramente tutti ma
favi ma alla fine rudy ha detto sì o ha
detto no qui non ho fatto in tempo a
chiedere a rudy in quel giorno se per
lui era sì o no però vedevo che
riprendeva con il telefono quindi era
preso bene però ragazzi come anch'io
l'ho sapere se era un sì o un no deciso
di chiamare a rudy zerbi qua a casa mia
oggi per farci appunto dire se era un sì
o no quindi adesso un attimo troviamo
crudi comunque per me è sì perfetto il
grafico grazie anche per me era si
andranno avanti ragazzi durante la
settimana abbiamo fatto
tenetevi pronti che sabato essere una
crossbar challenge vi dico solo questo
era da un anno che non facevamo una
cross bar e questa ci sono delle cose
che non avete idea e in questa challenge
che ho fatto con ipantellas che volo di
gonzales ne frega e l'ho fatta anche con
un mio amico che è che ecco che il
ragazzo che ogni tanto avete nei video e
insieme a lui abbiamo provato a fare un
fidget spinner di ghiaccio perché ormai
abbiamo sfruttato stamani a dei widget
spinner che tanto facciamole virus se
mettiamo figel spinner nel titolo però
in questo titolo non ce l'ho messo
perché sono click bait ma fino a un
certo punto abbia fatto un figel spinner
di ghiaccio che è una figata assurda gli
eventi momenti salienti di quello che è
successo
right now medio oggi siamo qui per fare
un nuova sfida ma devo farlo anche la
sola quanto pare di magno male prendiamo
il nostro figlio e spinner e doniamo
fidget fine che ottenete nelle dita
bravo grazie
dovremmo versare la quantità giusta di
acqua nel nostro contenitore hilfiger
spinner in questo modo sia perfetta
sentito uno scienziato scienziato e
ganso spazi poi fatto io sono un perito
chimico signorini 25 anni di merito
chirico per riuscire a mettere
dell'acqua in un contenitore bravissimo
rimane che mettere il nostro feed reader
di acqua in ferite per trasformarlo
ghiaccio va bene era spenta che non c'è
molto in film era più posto per posto ma
privo sotto come anche quella sorta
città canoni che dovrebbe essere pronto
marche fitalia se il freddo ma dai
poi bagna lo vediamo un po che del ceo
del corsivo bagniamo funziona benissimo
si può anche mangiare bravissimo mi fa
schifo
no non lo voglio a ifa iscritti denuncio
quindi ragazzi il suo viso in
descrizione completo di jospin di
ghiaccio di di ecco io ho ragazzi vi
dico che sabato prossimo uscirà la
crossbar challenge con ipantellas che
sarà video top della finita poi non
avete idea di che cosa non è successo in
quella roba lì spero che vi piaccia
ragazzi o completo che questo blog sono
raffreddato come lo schifo e non mi
crescono le medicine nella credenza
purtroppo invece quando vivevo in casa
quei miei spuntavano fuori a caso era un
bel periodo
quindi ragazzi spero che i titoli sia
piaciuto come al solito si sveglia è
piaciuto al momento non mi piace anche
la risorsa che come dice tiziana allora
si rischia da vinci mediano possiamo
visto le ragazze
[Musica]
ma